énormément monté je vais te produire
également à la radio je l'ai mis sur
Virgin Radio il arrive la fin de la
saison et il me dit je lui dis qu'est-ce
que tu veux faire et je te produit une
série ce qui rêvait de faire une série
sur Canal+ Canal+ il me disent banco on
fait comme tu as dit on est prêt à
luciner le contrat donc j'entendais que
il lui aurait proposé de faire qui veut
gagner des millions et Danse avec les
stars donc je veux dire Camille si
j'entends ça si tu as envie de faire
Danse avec les stars et qui veut gagner
des Millions
dis-le-moi franchement je peux
comprendre là il me dit non non pas du
tout franchement je te le dis pour qu'il
part comme ça je le laisse réfléchir
j'ai plus de nouvelles il arrive la fin
de la saison et je vois bon dans Le
Parisien une interview de Camille Combal
Camille Combal va sur TF1 et il dit je
vais il va faire danser avec les stars
et qui veut gagner des millions
donc je l'ai même pas appelé je vous dis
que c'est terminé comme ça on s'est pas
appelé je l'ai jamais eu au tel je l'ai
eu après je l'ai croisé une fois dans la
rue je vous dis la vérité c'est que ça
me fait de la peine quand j'ai travaillé
un talon pendant des années des semaines
et des semaines